احييكم مشاهدينا واهلا بكم الى هذه
التغطيه المستمره من العربيه اذا واحده من
اكبر التطورات في روسيا واوكرانيا منذ
اندلاع الحرب قبل اكثر من عام استهداف
بالطائرات المسيره خلال الليل للكرملين
حيث المجمع الرئاسي لاكبر قوه نوويه في
العالم روسيا اتهمت اوكرانيا بالضلوع وراء
الحادث وتعهدت باحتفاظها بحق الرد في
الوقت والمكان المناسبين اما اوكرانيا
فتنفي وتقول انه هجوما كهذا لا يحقق لها
اي اهداف او انها تعرف ان ذلك سيتسبب في
رد فعل متطرف ونفي الاوكراني ليس غريبا
فمن قبل نفت هجمات كبيره كاستهداف جسر
القرم وتفجير خط الغاز نورث ستريم تحت
البلطيق الا ان روسيا ايضا تكذب الروايات
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
هذا واتهمت روسيا اوكرانيا بانها حاولت
مهاجمه الكريم باستخدام مسيرات في محاوله
الاغتيال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين واعلنت
الرئاسه الروسيه اسقاط طائرتين مسيرتين
حاولتا استهداف مقر الرئاسه الروسيه كما
اعلن عمده موسكو صبيانين حظر استخدام اي
طائرات مدنيه غير مصرح لها في العاصمه
الى ذلك قال الرئيس الاوكرانيه ان
اوكرانيا لا تهاجم بوتين او موسكو ولكنها
تقاتل على اراضيها واضاف زيلينس كان بوتين
زيف الهجوم من اجل تحفيز شعبه للالتفاف
حوله في الحرب رئيس اوكرانيا قال ان بلاده
لا تسعى لقتل بوتين لكنها تترك الامر
للمحكمه في اشاره الى مذكره اعتقال بوتين
امام المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه والدعاوى
الاوكرانيه الاخرى بشان ارتكاب جرائم حرب
قبل ذلك قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه انه لا
علاقه لها بهجمات الطائرات من دون طيار
والتي تعرض لها الكرملين وبانها تركز
حاليا على تحرير اراضيها التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الروسيه الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
بالخدعه وبانها مقدمه لهجوم روسي شامل كما
اشارت الى ان المعارضه الروسيه قد تكون
وراء الهجوم على الكريم
فيما يتعلق بالطائرات بدون طيار فوق
الكرملين فالامر واضح تماما اولا وقبل كل
شيء بالطبع اوكرانيا لا علاقه لها بها
لانها لا تحل اي مهام عسكريه ثانيا من
المهم بالتاكيد بالنسبه لنا تدمير جميع
الاهداف العسكريه الروسيه في اراضينا
لتسريع عمليه انهاء الاحتلال وهذه مهمه
استراتيجيه ذات قيمه ثالثا ستفسر روسيا اي
اعمال اخرى على انها اعمال ارهابيه ما
سيتيح لها تبرير هجماتها الارهابيه واسعه
النطاق ضد المدنيين والبنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في اوكرانيا لذلك من المهم للغايه
الابلاغ عن حدثين غريبين حدث اليوم الاول
كان احتجاز المخربين الاوكرانيين
المفترضين في القرم والذين قيل انهم
يخططون لارتكاب عمل ارهابيه ثانيا تشير
الطائرات بدون طيار فوق الكرملين الى ان
روسيا تعد خلفيه معلوماتيه معينه لتبرير
اعم الها الارهابيه واسعه النطاق لذا
دعونا نرى ما الذي ستفعله روسيا اؤكد مره
اخرى ان مهاجمه الكرملين بطائرات بدون
طيار ليس هدفا لاوكرانيا
ونتوقف مشاهدينا مع هذه المواقف للامم
المتحده التي تقول بل تدعو روسيا
واوكرانيا للتخلي عن الخطوات التي تؤدي
للتصعيد ايضا الالوان المتحده تقول لا
يمكننا تاكيد المعلومات حول هجمات
اوكرانيا على الكرملين
وقالت ايضا الامم المتحده بانه هذه
طبعا ادعت روسيا واوكرانيا للتخلي عن هذه
الخطوات التي تؤدي للتصعيد اذا هذه اخر
المواقف للامم المتحده وكان هناك ايضا
مواقف للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وطبعا
كان هناك رد وانا فين كان من قبل روسيا او
من قبل اوكرانيا الان سنتوقف مع الصور
الجديده التي اظهرت قبه الكريم صباح اليوم
بعد تعرضها لهذا الهجوم
[موسيقى]
وكانت مشاهدينا وسائل الاعلام تحدثت عن
بعض المعلومات وانما الكرملين الان يؤكد
بانه المسيره الاولى انفجرت فوق قصر مجلس
الشيوخ وتسببت بحريق ايضا الكريملين قال
سته عشره دقيقه بين هجمات المسيرتين على
مقر اقامه بوتين كما قال بان المسيره
الثانيه تحطمت على اراضي قصر الكرملين اذا
هذه معلومات مؤكده الان من قبل الكريم
طبعا كان تم تداولها منذ ساعات من وسائل
اعلام سينضم الي الان من كياف الصحفيه
محمد البابا من امام الكريم ليلا تنضم
الينا زميلتنا كاتيا بمراسله العربيه اهلا
بكما ابدا معك كاتيا الوضع الان وانت
بالقرب الامن الكريم كيف تبدو الاجواء
الاجراءات الامنيه
مرحبا ميسون بالفعل نحن نقف الان امام
الكرملين الوضع والامن مستقر في المنطقه
وكما ترين من خلف الكريم لن تظهر سوره
الكرمل من خلفي بعد الهجوم المسيرات الذي
بدا او كان ليله امس طبعا هذا هو الحائط
المحائط الذي يحيط بالكرملين وكما تشاهدين
العلم الذي هو على القبه التي سقطت عليها
المسيره لا يوجد اي اثار لسقوط هذه
المسيرات او الحريق الذي اندلعها طبعا كان
هناك حسب
تناقلت وسائل الاعلام روسيه لفيديوهات
حريق صغير مصغر في هذه المنطقه تم السيطره
او اخماده بشكل مباشر وايضا الرجال الامن
يحاوطون جميع الساحه الحمراء في من كل
الجهات
طبعا منع دخول او دخول السيارات الى داخل
الساحه الحمراء لان طبعا كما ترين ايضا
هناك الاعلام الحمراء والزرقاء هي تحضيرات
لعيد النصر والتدريبات التي تقام قبيله
الاحتفالات بعيد النصر الامن قبيله اسبوع
من عيد النصر يكون مكثف ومشدد في داخل
العاصمه روسيا موسكو وبالاخص في الساحه
الحمراء يكون هناك تجديد امن واسع يتم منع
دخول المره او مرور السيارات من داخل
الساحه او من جانب الساحه الحمراء
وبالتالي تكثيف الامن الان اصبح اكبر بعد
الهجوم الذي تعرض له الكريمينيوم امس من
قبل المسيارتين والتي تم صدها من قبل
الاستخبارات الروسيه والرجال الامن
الروسيه ميسون دعوني اذكر بكل هذه
المعلومات التي ترد على لسان من الكرملين
بان الهجوم على الكرملين لم يغير جدول
اعمال الرئيس بوتين وبان الرئيس بوت كان
متواجدا بمقر اقامته بضواحي موسكو لحظه
الهجوم وبان هذه المسيرات كانت تستهدف مقر
اقامه بوتين في الكرملين وبان هذا الهجوم
بالمسيرات بدا في الساعه الثانيه والنصف
صباحا بتوقيت موسكو تحديدا ثانيه و27
دقيقه
قال المسيره الثانيه تحطمت على اراضي قصر
الكرملين والمسيره الاولى انفجرت فوق قصر
مجلس الشيوخ وتسببت بحريق وبان هناك 16
دقيقه بين هجمات المسيرتين على مقر اقامه
بوتين اعود اليكم محمد البابا بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا ابرز المواقف الان بعد هذا
الاستهداف للكرملين وكما قيل محاوله
اغتيال الرئيس بوتين
يعني جاء الرد والنفي الكامل من كلمه
الرئيس الاوكراني الذي اعتبر ما حصل انها
خدعه تريد من خلالها موسكو تاجيج الوضع
وايضا خلق زريعه لعدوان او عمليه اجراميه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ايضا المتحدث باسم
الاداره الرئاسيه او المكتب الرئاسي
قال في يعني تغريده له على شبكه تويتر
وعلى تيليجرام انه لا علاقه لاوكرانيا
بالهجوم الذي حصل في موسكو ليله امس ايضا
متحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه نفع
ان يكون الجيش الاوكراني او الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه قد قامت بعمليه اطلاق
مسيرات باتجاه قصر الكرملين يعني حتى
الراي العام الاوكراني ووسائل الاعلام
الاوكرانيه تشكك يعني بفرضيه ان تكون
اوكرانيا قد اطلقت هذه المسيره والسيناريو
التي تحدثنا عنه طيله النهارده السيناريو
الاول وهو اعتبار من يعني الراي العام
الاوكراني وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه وحتى
جميع السياسيين يعتبرون ان هذه خدعه او
مسرحيه قد قامت بها الاستخبارات الروسيه
لتاجيج الوضع في الوضع بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا وخلق زريعه للقيام بعمليات
انتقاميه خاصه تزامنت وبعد يعني هذه وبعد
اعلان موسكو عن هذه المسيرتين التي
استهدفتاه الكرملين بدا الحديث ومطالبات
من الجانب الروسي والسياسيين والنواب
الروس
باستهداف روسيا والجيش الروسي للمراكز
الحكوميه الاوكرانيه حتى كان هناك مطالبات
باغتيال الرئيس ايزيلنسكي وتوجيه ضربه حول
يعني حول واحتيال القيادات الاوكرانيه
لذلك ما يعني الراي العام الاوكراني وجميع
التصريحات من وزاره الداخليه وزاره
الخارجيه وزاره الدفاع وحتى الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه يصفون ما حصل يعني فيلم او بي
يعني مسرحيه تقول خدعه كما وصف التحديدا
هي خدعه تقوم بها روسيا محمد ساعود اليك
لنتعرف ايضا اذا كان هناك من اجراءات
جديده بعد من هذا الحادث ولكن اريد ان
اذهب مجددا الى زميلتنا كاتيا من امام
كاتيا طبعا كنت ذكرتي بانه يوم النصر يعني
هو طبعا في التاسع من هذا الشهر
يعني بانه هذا الامر او هذا الحدث لن يؤثر
على هذا اليوم وبوتين سيكون متواجدا ولكن
هل هناك مؤشرات على الاستعداد لهذا اليوم
وبانه لا شيء اتغير
اولا ميسون ابدا من تصريحات الكرملين
انه لا تغيير في خطط عقد احتفالات عيد
النصر يوم التاسع من الشهر الجاري
وبالتالي الرئيس الروسي طبعا بنفسه سيكون
حاضرا خلال هذه الاحتفالات وكما ترين
امامنا هناك الاعلام الحمراء والزرقاء
وهناك تقام الان وهناك سيارات التابعه
للدفاع الروسيه والتي هي الان تقوم
بالتدريب قبيله احتفالات عين النصر يتم
تجهيز هذه الساحه
وتزيينها بتزيينها بالاعلام قبيل بدء
الاحتفالات بفتره قبيله اسبوع من بدء
الاحتفالات وبالتالي حتى الان نحن نشاهد
ان كل شيء هو
مستمر لا يوجد اي انقطاع في هذه العمليه
عمليه التحضير وكما تحدث الكرملين واكد
انه لم يكن هناك تغيير في الخطط لعقد
احتفالات عيد النصر في موسكو انا اتحدث عن
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو ولكن كان هناك
تغييرات في بعض المدن الحدوديه بعض المدن
الحدوديه كانت قد تحدثت انها لن تقوم لن
تقوم
بالاحتفال عقد احتفالات عيد النصر تخوفا
من ان يكون هناك هجمات وبالاخص المناطق
الحدوديه مثل المدينه بريانس او مدينه
بورج بيرغورود التي تتعرض بشكل مستمر
لهجمات من قبل الجانب الاوكراني سواء كانت
به سيارات وبالاخص نحن الفتره الاخيره كنا
قد شهدنا هجمات مكثفه من الجانب الاوكراني
كانت قد استهدفت سواء كانت مؤسسات تتعلق
بالطاقه والنفط او كان هناك استهداف في
مدينه هناك موقف الان خطير لمدينه
يقول الان لا خيار امام روسيا الا قتل
زيلينسكي واعضاء حكومته اذا ايضا هذا موقف
روسي جديد على لسان ديميد فيدف الذي يقول
بانه لا خيار امام روسيا الان الا قتل
زيلينسكي واعضاء حكومته هنا اعود اليكم
محمد البابا هل هناك من اجراءات جديده
اتخذت للرئيس زيلينسكي لاعضاء حكومته
للمقر الحكوميه الرئاسه مقر الجيش
حتى هذه اللحظه لا يعني الحياه طبيعيه
وكما ترون يعني حركه السيارات بخلفي
طبيعيه الان في العاصمه الاوكرانيه خاصه
يعني بعد انتهاء الانذار الجوي الذي استمر
لمده ساعتين يعني في تلك الساعتين كان
هناك هجوم على بعض المناطق الاوكرانيه وفي
حصيله يعني حصيله نهائيه لعدد الضحايا
الذين سقطوا في مقاطعه حرسون 17 قتيلا و48
شريحا حتى هذه اللحظه في مقاطعه خرسون
التي يعني جاءت الضربات تزامنا مع الحديث
عن الضربات الصاروخيه او او المسيرات التي
طالت لذلك يعني هناك حذر كبير وترقب كبير
في الشارع الاوكراني والجميع يتحدث عن
نوعيه الرد ويتخوف من نوعيه الرجل التي
ستقوم به موسكو على هاتين او على هاتين
لا تتحدث بانه طلب من الناس في اكياد
خصوصا بالنزول الى الملاجئ
اثناء اثناء الانذار الجوي كان هناك دعوات
من يعني
مدير المكتب الرئاسي من وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني طالبوا جميع السكان بالنزول
خاصه في العاصمه الى الملاجئ اثناء فتره
الانذار الجوي ولكن الان في هذه الاثناء
لا انذار جوي في العاصمه الاوكرانيه هدوء
حظر ترقب لهذه الليله جميع اتحدث عن ربما
ستكون هذه الليله يعني شبيهه بما حصل
بالامس ليله امس كان هناك استهداف
بالمسيرات للعاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت 18 مسيره فوق سماء
العاصمه اوكرانيا
وايضا يعني الضربات الصاروخيه التي طالت
خرسون
خاركو وسومي هي ايضا تزامنت مع الانذار
الجو الان هناك ترقب الجميع ينتظر اللحظات
يعني الساعات المقبله خاصه ان الرئيس
زيلينسكي ليس متواجد داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه هو في فنلندا في زياره رسميه
الى فنلندا ومن المتوقع عندما يعود الى
اوكرانيا سيكون هناك موقف كبير للرئيس
الاوكراني خاصه انه خرج بمؤتمر صحفي وكلمه
يعني قبل دقائق او قبل حوالي 40 دقيقه من
الان تحدث
ونفعونيا بشكل كامل بالهجوم على على
واعتبر ان ما حصل هو خدعه لها اهداف قد
تقوم بها روسيا شكرا لك يا محمد كنت معي
كما اشكر زميلتنا كاتيا كانت معنا من امام
الكرملين
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان واشنطن لا
يمكنها التحقق من صحه تقارير استهدفت بل
استهداف بوتين
ان امريكا تنظر بعين الربا لكل ما يصدر عن
الكرملين مؤكدا انها لا تعرف ما الذي حدث
في الكرام للنمل كما قال بلينكن ان قرارات
اوكرانيا لكيفيه الدفاع عن نفسها تعود لها
او عشره واثقه بان اوكرانيا ستنجح
باستعاده ما تبقى من اراضيها
من واشنطن ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
بيرغانم كير اهلا بك معنا فضلا عن الذي
تحدث به وزير الخارجيه عن توني بلينكن هل
هناك من مواقف جديده من قبل الولايات
المتحده تجاه هذا الحادث في في روسيا
وايضا اتجاه التصريحات التي تصدر عن
الكرملين
اعتقد ان موقف بلينكن يعبر بشكل كبير عن
موقف الاداره الامريكيه ومواقف الامريكيين
بشكل عام حول ما يحدث وهي تنقسم الى جزئين
الجزء الاول هو ان الامريكيين وكما ذكرتي
انت قبل قليل لا يثقون باي اخبار تقولها
روسيا حول ما يجري في موسكو او على ساحه
المعركه الجزء الثاني المهم وهو ان
الامريكيين كان لديهم اتفاق مع اوكرانيا
على ان لا تقوم اوكرانيا بشن هجمات على
الاراضي الروسيه ولكن هذا الموضوع اختلف
قليلا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه شاهدنا عده
عمليات على القطارات التي تنقل الشحنات
باتجاه اوكرانيا وشاهدنا ايضا بعد
العمليات في جزيره القرب وبالتالي هناك
بعض الشكوك حتى لدى الامريكيين حول ما
يقوم به الاوكرانيون وتخفي كل هذه المساله
حقيقه ما يحدث في الميدان في اوكرانيا هل
هناك من او توقعات مثلا خاصه بعد هذا
الحادث ان يكون هناك اجراءات تغيير ما في
السياسه الخاصه باوكرانيا ام من المبكر
الحديث عن ذلك
الامريكيون يتوقعون ان تكون روسيا بعمليه
قصف واسعه وربما محاوله هجوم بري في محور
جديد على الاراضي الاوكرانيه وهذا ما
يخشونه بشكل خاص لكنهم يشعرون انهم اعطوا
الاوكرانيين ما يكفي من الدفاعات الجويه
للدفاع عن انفسهم ودورهم ايضا الكثير من
المعدات لشن هجوم بري الحقيقه هي ما يحدث
على الارض في اوكرانيا وليس ما حدث في
موسكو وربما تشهد الايام القليله المقبله
تحركات كبيره على الارض اكانا من جانب
الروس او من جانب الاوكرانيه يعني هل
نتوقع مثلا زياده ما
بالاسلحه التي
تعطى لاوكرانيا ان كان من قبل الولايات
المتحده او حتى من قبل الناتو بعد هذا
التصعيد الكبير بالمواقف الروسيه ان كان
من خلال الكرمله من خلال الانمي الذي قال
بانه يعني يجب قتل زيلينسكي الان واعضاء
حكومته
لم يتحدث الامريكيون خلال الساعات او
الايام الماضيه عن مزيد من الاسلحه التي
تعطى لاوكرانيا ولكن اوكرانيا تلقت خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه كميات هائله من الذخيره
تلقت ايضا دفاعات جويه تلقت مدرعات
وسيارات مصفحه ودبابات مصنعه امريكيا او
اوروبيا وهي بوضعيه جيده لشان هجوم عندما
تريد ربما يساعد الوضع لو كان هناك هجوم
صاروخي اضافي من قبل الروس لدفع
الامريكيين لارسال المزيد من الذخائر ومن
الدفاعات الجويه ولكن ما حدث بدون شك خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه والاشهر الماضيه الماضيه
من دعم عسكري لاوكرانيا يكفيها اقله في
المرحله الحاليه لشن هجوم مضاد وربما
تحرير بعض الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي
احتلتها القوات الروسيه بالنسبه للتامين
الحمايه للرئيس بعد هذا الكلام بانه يجب
قتله قتل اعضاء حكومته هل نتوقع مثلا
اي مساعده من الولايات المتحده لتامين
حمايته مثلا
كاستخبارات او معلومات استخباراتيه هل
يمكن ان
تحفز بطريقه اكبر خصن الان اصبح الخطر
اكبر بعد هذه التصريحات
الامريكيون ساعدوا الاوكرانيين بالعمليات
الاستخباراتيه منذ ما قبل ما بدات المعارك
في اوكرانيا وبدون شك انه يسخرون الاله
الاستخباراتيه الكبيره التي لديهم واقصد
هنا الولايات المتحده على الامريكيه
لمساعده اوكرانيا وبدون شك لو كانت هناك
ايه مؤشرات على ان روسيا او اي طرف اخر
يعمل لصالح روسيا يهدد حياه الرئيس
الاوكراني فسوف يلجا الامريكيون الى
المساعده سنعود اليك دائما بارغانم
لمتابعه اي مواقف جديده من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اتجاه هذا الحادث الذي
اليوم طاله الكرملين وما قيل بانه محاوله
اغتيال الرئيس بوتين شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
مجلس دوما الروسيه توجيهه لتوجيه رد قاسم
على محاولات استهداف الكريم التي كانت
تهدف الاغتيال الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين حيث
قام باطلاق نداء لتدمير نظام بعد الهجوم
على الكرملين وقال مجلس الدمى الروسي بان
الهجوم على الكرملين سببا لاطلاق حرب
حقيقيه باوكرانيا وبان الوقت حان لاطلاق
هجوم صاروخيه على مقر اقامه الرئيس
الاوكراني
اظهر مقطع الفيديو الذي نشره الكرملين ما
يرجح انهما رجل امنا كان يصعدان على قبه
المبنى قبل استهداف المسيره بثوان هذا
وقمر بنشر الفيديو بالفيديو الاستهداف
الذي جرى فجر اليوم بحسب تقديرات اوليا
ولم يذكر ما اذا كان رجلا امني في مهمه
امنيه لاعتراض او تشويش على المسيرتين
مؤكدا في بيان عدم وقوع اي ضحايا او اضرار
ماديه
قال رئيس مجموعه
فاجنريجوجين ان اوكرانيا بدات الان هجومها
المضاد واضاف في بيان له عبر تطبيق
تيليجرام ان قواته لاحظت نشاطا غير معهودا
للقوات الاوكرانيه على طول الجبهه كما
توقع ان تنتقل الاشتباكات الى مرحله اكثر
نشاطا في الايام القليله الماضيه
من موسكو ينضم الي يزجيني سيدرا في المحلل
السياسي اهلا بك معنا هل ما حصل اليوم في
الكرملين يمكن القول عنه بانه تم تجاوز
الحدود الحمراء
تحيه لك ميسون والاستاد المشاهدين الى
درجه معينه يمكن القول انما حدثه بالفعل
تجاوز خطوط الحمر التي تم تحديدها في هذه
المعارك وفي هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
كما تسميها موسكو لكن المهم هنا برايي
الاشاره الى توقيت هذا الحادث ليس من قبيل
الصدفه انه حدث قبل ايام معدودات من
احتفال روسيا كلها باهم اعيادها الوطنيه
وهو عيد النصر على المانيا الناجيه في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه يبدو وكانها من
دبر مثل هذه
الحادثه كان يعول ربما على اثاره الخوف
والزعر لدى
المواطنين الروس والذين ربما الكثير منهم
يتوقع ان يشارك في هذه الاحتفالات لكي
يبقوا ربما في البيوت او يذهبوا الى خارج
موسكو خوفا من استهدافات اخرى ولكن لا
اعتقد بان ما حدث ربما حقق اهداف اليك
الذين خططوا لهذه العمليه واضح تماما ايضا
بالاضافه الى هذا
في اي علاقه لها بما حصل اليوم من
المستفيد اذا لم تكن اوكرانيا من قامت
بهذا الفعل من المستفيد من هي الايدي خاصه
بان هذه المسيره لم تطلق من مكان بعيد
اطلقت من مكان قريب جدا من الساحه الحمراء
ومن قلب موسكو
نعم وتحديدا في قلب بوسكو وحتى في يعني
مقر اقامه بوتين خلال الايام الاخيره لان
الناطق الصحفي بيسبي الرئيس الروسي قال
عده مرات منذ ايام ان الرئيس الروسي يباد
في هذه في هذا المقر بالكرملين لكثره
انشغاله بالامور الحاليه ومنها بطبيعه
الحال وفي المقام الاول العمليه العسكريه
في اوكرانيا ولكن بالعوده الى سؤالك اعتقد
بان هناك ايضا هدف اخر وهو ان هذا الحادث
يكاد يتزامن مع ما يتوقعه الكثيرون في
العالم من بدء اوكرانيا بالهجوم المضاد
ليس فقط
صرح اليوم كما قيل الان منذ قليل بان
اوكرانيا بدت عمليه بدات الهجوم المضاد
انما حتى مصادر مواله لاوكرانيا ومنها
ممثلي السلطات
في خرسون في مدينه خرسون اكدوا على ان من
يجري الان يمكن وصفه بانه مؤشر على بدايه
هذا الهجوم الذي قال
رئيسها تقول بانها هي لا تستهدف موسكو هي
فقط تحاول استرجاع اراضيها يعني هذا
الهجوم المضاد الذي تريد ان تقوم به
اوكرانيا لا علاقه له بموسكو بالكرملين
بهذا الحادث حسب ما هي تصرح
ولكن يبدو ان الرئيس اليونس ليس هو صاحب
القرار لسببين
اولهما ان هناك متشددين في القياده
الاوكرانيه
ومنهم من يدعو الى استهداف موسكو واذا لم
يكن امر الامر كذلك فلماذا تحذر المانيا
مثلا عده مرات خلال الايام الاخيره من ان
اوكرانيا لا يمكن ان تستهدف اراضي روسيا
هذا يعني ان هناك اشارات
وصلت الى المانيا وربما الى الولايات
المتحده بان هناك من في القياده
الاوكرانيه يخطط لبس هذه الاستهدافات
لانه اوكرانيا قامت بهذا الفعل طب من
المنفذ المنفذ هو في قلب موسكو في قلب
روسيا هذه الثغره الامنيه كيف يمكن ان
تتعامل معها روسيا
الصقره الامنيه بطبيعه الحال موجوده لان
اذا نظرنا الى الايام الاخيره هناك عده
استهدافات
لمستودع للنفط ولشكك الحديديه احد
القطارات خرج عن مساره كما نعلم هناك عدد
اخر من حالات استهداف المسيرات لمناطق
قريبه من موسكو طبعا لابد من ربما التركيز
على تقويه وتعزيز الدفاعات الجويه التي
تدافع عن سماء موسكو وعن موقع موسكو بوجه
عام ولكن من الخبراء من يرى ان هناك
مفارقه يعني المسيرات حتى اذا كانت يدويه
الصنع او بدائيه يمكن ان تخترق المجال
الجوي بسهوله اكثر من المسيرات الحربيه
العسكريه كبيره الحجم وهذا الامر ربما
يشير الى ان هناك بالفعل بعض الثغرات التي
لابد من تجنبها ويبدو ان القوات
والمصادر والاجهزه الامنيه تعمل على ازاله
مثل هذه الثغرات الان طب يعني مثلا مجلس
الدمى نعود ونذكر طبعا بما قال بان بعض
الهجوم على انتهت فرص المفاوضات مع بعد
هذا الموقف وهذا الموقف يعني اتخذه مجلس
الدمى منذ طبعا تقريبا اكثر من ساعه هل
سيكون
هذه العمليه العسكريه التي تصر دائما
موسكو بان تسميها عمليه عسكريه وليست حرب
بعد هذا الحادث هل ستتحول حقيقه الى حرب
مفتوحه
ولابد من انتظار بعض الوقت لان الرئيس
الروسي معروف بانه يتخذ قرارات مفاجئه
ربما لا يتوقعها احد وليس بالضروره ان
يلبي مطالب اليك الذين يعني يطالبونه
بضروره الرد وتصفيه كما قال نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن تصفيه الرئيس الينسكي وزمرته
وكان هناك ليس من خيار اخر انا متاكد بان
الرئيس بوتين سوف يتخذ قرارات مفاجاه وليس
بالضروره ان تكون هذه الخطوات او هذا الرد
في الايام القليله الماضيه ولا سيما
الاليام المتبقيه حتى عيد النصر لان
التصعيد بطبيعه الحال لا يدخل في خطط ربما
موسكو قبيله هذا العيد اما فيما بعد وربما
هناك
التطورات سوف تتضامن مع بدء الهجوم
الحقيقي المضاد للقوات الاوكرانيه فربما
سنرى هذا الرد وطبيعته ولكن
هو فتح وليس ليس على مصارعه وانما فتح
ربما بشكل جزئي ان صح التعبير وربما لابد
من توقع رد فعل قوي جدا ولكن ليس خلال وقت
قصيره ووقت قريب جدا بالنسبه ايضا لموضوع
والولايات المتحده لطالما دائما روسيا
تقول بانه الولايات المتحده هي تريد ان
تورط اوروبا
هل بهذا الحادث الذي حصل اليوم ساعيضا
نشهد مواقف حازمه تجاه اوروبا واتجاه
الولايات المتحده من قبل روسيا
انا لا استبعد بان هناك ربما خلاف قوي بين
الولايات المتحده من جهه ودول الاوروبيه
التي لا تريد ان تدخل في مواجهه مع موسكو
يعني اقصد الدول الاوروبيه منها المانيا
وفرنسا على سبيل المثال وحتى الدول التي
تتميز مواقفها بالتشدد مثل بولندا ودول
البلطيق لا اعتقد بان من مصالحهم ان يستمر
هذا التصعيد ويصل الى صدام مباشر بينها
وبين روسيا اما الولايات المتحده فالصوره
بالنسبه لي يبدو انها اكثر تعقيدا وانا لا
استبعد بان قرار اوكرانيا اذا تاكد هذا
الاستهداف من قبل القوات او الاجهزه
الامنيه الاوكرانيه قرار اوكرانيا لم يكن
قرارا مستقلا وانما هناك نصيحه وردت اليها
ربما من بعض القوى التي تريد بالفئه ان
تصل بالامور الى حد مثل هذا التصادم
التصادم واختبار مدى الرد روسيا على هذه
الجهه هل هي الولايات المتحده هل هي دوله
اوروبيه بعينها من هي هذه الدوله التي
تريد تصعيد هذا الحد
بما ان هناك يعني بعض التسريبات التي تقول
ان الولايات المتحده قررت اضعاف وانهاك
موسكو فانا لاستبعد ان المصدر الذي قدم
هذه النصيحه الى القياده الاوكرانيه هو
وراء المحيط وتحديدا في واشنطن ولكن
واشنطن دائما تقول بانه لا يمكن ان تستفز
روسيا او غيرها من الدول التي تمتلك اسلحه
نوويه حتى يتم استخدامها خاصه بان روسيا
منذ بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه دائما
تتحدث عن موضوع الاسلحه النوويه والحرب
النوويه خاصه سيد
لا لا نفس الصوره مثل ما هي في اوكرانيا
هناك عده معسكرات وعده قوه وهناك تناقض
وتضارب في مصالحها فيما بينها وبالتالي لا
استبعد بان هناك رؤوس حاميه في الاداره
الامريكيه وهي تحاول ان تحوص الرئيس بايدن
الى الانتقال الى تدابير اكثر حزما تجاه
روسيا
يكتفي بيدا بمجرد زياده
توريدات الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا وانما ينتقل
الى ربما خطوات اكثر حزما تجاه روسيا
لانهاء قدراتها ولتحويلها الى دوله ربما
ليس بمقدورها ان تستمر في هذه العمليه
اسمح لي ان تبقى معي ساذهب الى مراسلنا
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل من كيف حذيفه
اهلا بك معنى كيف يمكن ان تصف لنا الاجواء
الان في كاف بعد هذا التصعيد الكبير
مساء الخير طبعا الوضع في كيف على مستوى
المدينه لم يتغير باي شكل من الاشكال طبعا
كان هنالك حالتين من الانذار الجوي
بسبب ان هنالك كان استهداف في مناطق واسعه
طبعا لم تطال العاصمه كيف اي ضربه حتى هذه
اللحظه ولكن الانذار الجوي توقفت الاعمال
توقفت المؤسسات خرج الناس البعض منهم لجا
الى الملاجئ الموجوده في هذه المؤسسات او
المراكز التجاريه وغيرها ولكن لم يعني
الاغلبيه منهم ايضا بقوا في الشوارع لم
يذهبوا حتى الى الملاجئ الوضع هادئ جدا لا
يوجد اي حاله من الهلع او الخوف من رشح في
الاعلام حول انه هنالك هجمه قد تكون
انتقاميه للعاصمه اكيد سابتعد قليلا فقط
من امام الكاميرا لتشاهدي الان انا في
احدى في احد الشوارع في وسط العاصمه كيف
الناس بهدوء يجلسون الان في
الطرقات او على الاراي هنا في هذا الطريق
فالوضع هذه جدا ولكن طبعا على الاعلام حتى
في الاعلام المحلي الاوكراني هنالك حديث
واسعا انه يمكن ان تكون هنالك هجمات
انتقاميه المواطنين يترقبون السلطات تعمل
على اجراءات مثلا حذيفه يتم الحديث عنها
بالنسبه للناس بحال تم اي هجوم خلال
الساعات المقبله وخاصه على كيف
نعم تحدثت بشكل شخصي الى بعض المواطنين
سالتهم اذا كانوا يخافون من اي هجمات
انتقاميه او اي هجمات من قبل
الكريملين في يعني حول هذا الامر حول
رد فعل على الاتهام كيف بهذا التفجير الذي
تم فيه الناس يقولون ان هذه مسرحيه وهم
ايضا طبعا استمعوا الى السلطات الاوكرانيه
استمعوا الى
مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني كذلك قياده القوات
الجويه ايضا تحدثت حول الامر واصدرت بيان
واستمعوا اليه وهم يصدقون ان هذه مسرحيه
من قبل الكريم ليقوم بهاجمات خاصه في
التاسع مما يو في عيد النصر الروسي وان
الوضع في باق موت استصعب على الروس لذلك
هم يبحثون عن اي فعل يستطيع ان يهدئ من
الداخل الروسي ايضا سالتهم اذا كانوا
سيتبعون اي اجراءات قالوا سيكونون بشكل
طبيعي اذا ما حدثت هجماتك التي تحدث طبعا
لابد هنا ان اشير انا في الاسبوع الماضي
ارتفعت وتيره الهجمات على كيف كان هنالك
ثلاثه هجمات في السته ايام الماضيه على
عكس قبل ذلك كانت تكون هنالك هجمه واحده
في الشهر او على اكثر تقدير هجمتين في
الشهر على العاصمه كيف تحديدا طبعا اتحدث
وقالوا انه سيتبعون الاجراءات العاديه
سيذهبون الى الملاجئ في حال حدوث اي غاره
جويه او انذار جوي او هجمه جويه نحو
العاصمه كيف ولكن اذا اصبح الامر بشكل
واسع النطاق وهجوم مكثف سيبدا الناس طبعا
باخذ التدابير العاديه التي كانوا
ياخذونها اما الخروج من العاصمه كييف الى
مناطق اكثر امنا اذا كان الاستهداف فقط
للعاصمه كيف الجميع يتوقع ان الهجوم قد
يكون فقط في العاصمه كيف قد يكون في وسط
العاصمه كيف حيث نحن الان خاصه في مناطق
صنع القرار نتحدث عن مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني نتحدث عن وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه وزاره الداخليه ايضا البرلمان
كل هذه المشاهدين
الاجراءات تغيرت اجراءات امنيه تغيرت بعد
هذا التصعيد في الساعات الماضيه ام لا حول
هذه المقر نعم لم يتغير
نعم لم يتغير اي شيء هذه المغاره هي
بالفعل تحت حراسه مشدده هنالك اجراءات
امنيه مشدده منذ او اليوم الاول للحرب
وحتى اليوم لم تخف ولم تتغير هنالك بعض
الدوريات في في محيط هذه
يعني المرافق الحكوميه ومراكز صنع القرار
كذلك هنالك ارتكازات للجيش الاوكراني
لجهاز الامن الوطني هذا الامر لم يتغير
طبعا مكتب الرئيس ومحيطه حتى المباني
السكنيه هي مغلقه تماما لا يمكن الدخول
الا باذونات معينه حتى المواطنين الذين
يسكنون في هذا المحيط لديهم تصاريح خاصه
تثبت انهم يسكنون في هذه المناطق حتى
سياراتهم يتم تفتيشهم ويتم تفتيش السيارات
للدخول الى هذا المحيط والاجراءات لم
تتغير منذ اليوم الاول للحرب وحتى الان
ولم تخف لذلك الاجراءات المشدده هي موجوده
اما في بقيه المناطق لا نلاحظ اي تغيير لا
يوجد اي انتشار اوسع مثلا لل ولكن الجميع
لاهبه الاستعداد طبعا الدفاع المدني على
هبه الاستعداد كما افادت السلطات انهم
جاهزون لاي هجمات الدفاع الجوي قال ايضا
انه جاهز لسطح اي هجمات نحو العاصمه ولكنه
حذر ايضا المواطنين باخذ الحيطه والحذر
وايضا لا يهمل يعني الاعلان عن الانذار
الجوي لان المواطنين في الفتره الاخيره
تعودوا على حالات الانذار الجوي او التي
في الغالب لا تصل الى العاصمه كيف يتم
صدها خاصه بعد ان حصلت كيف على عدد مقدر
من انظمه الدفاع الجوي وهي خلاف عددها
ايضا هي متطوره وحديثه واصبحت تعمل بكفاءه
اعلى واصبحت تصب الهجمات الجويه بنسبه
فاقه التسعين في المئه في اخر ثلاث هجمات
نحو العاصمه كيف استطاعت ان تسقط في هجمه
كانت حوالي 20 صاروخا اسقطت 19 منهم
الهجمه التي سبقتها كانت حوالي 30 صاروخا
ايضا اسقطت 28 او 29 يعني لا اذكر بالضبط
والهجمه التي كانت قبلها ايضا تم استهداف
كيف 32 صاروخا اسقطت السلطات او اسد اسقط
الدفاع الجوي 30 صاروخا منها لذلك النسبه
ارتفعت جدا كانت النسبه قبل حوالي شهرين
67% الان ارتفعت الى ما يقارب التسعين في
المئه طبعا ايضا تحدث الشريفاتي وهو
الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات في الشرق وقال
ان هذه المسرحيه هي رده فعل على عدم قدره
موسكو على اتمام
بداته في باخموت واعر السيطره الكامله على
بخموت وقال ان الدفاع ما زال مستمرا في
مدينه باغموت هي غير قادره وهذه الدعايه
التي روجوا لها انهم بحلول التاسع من هذا
الشهر سوف يحكمون سيطرتهم على مدينه باقمت
هذا مجرد زيف وقال ان القوات صامده في تلك
المنطقه طبعا هنالك تصريحات من عدد من
المسؤولين الناطق الرسمي باسم الرئاسه
الكسي
هو ايضا صرح وقال كيف غير مسؤوله تماما عن
هذا الهجوم نحو الكريملين وان الهجوم
الارهابي الحقيقي هو ما حدث في الايام
الماضيه في كيف وفي غيرها من المقاطعه
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل كنت معي من كيف
اعود الى ضيفنا من موسكو افقيني
هل يمكن اعتبار سيدافيني ان هذه العمليه
العسكريه التي تصر روسيا على تسميتها بذلك
ما قبل هذا التاريخ اليوم وهذا الاستهداف
للكرملين لن يكون كما بعده
لابد من انتظار بعض الوقت لاعتقد بان شيئا
ما سيحدث قبل الاحتفالات بعيد النصر لان
بطبيعه الحال القياده الروسيه لا تريد ان
تعكر صفو هذه الاحتفالات واجوائها كما كان
ذلك عاده حتى في ايام او في سنوات ما قبل
هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
واعتقد بان ربما التطورات البالغ الخطوره
والتصعيد سوف نشهده الحال في الايام التي
ستاتي في عقاب هذه الاحتفالات ربما في
اواسط هذا الشهر علما بان هناك ما يشير
الى امكانيه ان تبدا القوات الاوكرانيه
بالفعل بالهجوم المضاده على مختلف الجبهات
في اوكرانيا شكرا لك من موسكو اف جينيسي
درافا المحلل السياسي ساذهب الان الى كيف
عبر سكايب مع سفير فولوديميرو دبلوماسيه
السابق سيد فلومير اهلا بكم معنا هذا
الاتهام لكم بشكل مباشر بانكم انتم من
قمتم بهذا الاستهداف للكرملين وبمحاوله
اغتيال الرئيس الروسي انتم نفيتم ذلك ولكن
محاوله اغتيال رئيس دوله في قلب صراع
وهناك حرب بينكم وبين روسيا هذا امر يهدد
السلام العالمي من يمكن ان يقوم به
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
تحيه طيبه من اوكرانيا
بصراحه انا اعتقد شخصيا بان هذه استفزازات
روسيه
بان من الاربعه مستحيلات بان جيش روسي
يعاجس لحمايه الجو كريملين اين كل هذه
الانظمه الدفاع الجوي فيروسيه مثل
400 اس 500
يعني بصفه عامه مسرحيه روسيه وهي
بالمناسبه على مصلحه روسيه لماذا لان هذه
الضعيه ذريع للروس في عظم
الاتفاقيه الحبوب في اقرب ايام هذا كمان
ذريع لروس
لاستخدام اي نوع من الاسلحه على اوكرانيا
وكمان اصلح نوويه هجوم مضادات متوقعه قوات
مصالحه اوكرانيا
هل من الم مكن ان تقوم روسيا باستهداف
نفسها وبهذا المكان يعني هذا ايضا يؤثر
على هيبتها بانه تم استهداف هذا المكان
وهو رمزي وهو قلب القرار في موسكو
ولكن في عده
اصدارات من حقك هذا اوكرانيا اوكرانيا
ناخذ هذا
غير متوارطه بهذا هجوم كمان من الممكن بان
حدثتها هذا الهجوم ايضا مقاومه محليه تحت
الارض في المتطوعين الروس وكما نقول
الفكره لكنها للمعارضه لديها هذا
هذا مثلا هذه المسيرات هل المعارضه هي
قادره ان تمتلك مثل هذه الاستراتيجيات
للقيام بها من داخل روسيا بصراحه هذا غير
معروف وكمان واحد افاض افاضت اوكرانيا لا
توجد مسيرات مثل بعيد الماده
لاستهداف الكريم ولكن على كل حال بالنسبه
لي بالمناسبه غريبه جدا بان بعضها وهجوم
لا توجد اي اقالات واستقالات داخل روسيا
كل هذا
لمجنرال من وزاره الدفاع اذا كانت هذا
ليست استفزاز ماذا يعني ماذا يعني اذا اذا
لم يوجد هناك
استقالات الى ماذا تلمح
كما نقول بان هذه المسرحيه روسيه لكي تكون
الذريعه كما انا كنت اولا هذا عظم تمضيه
اتفاقيه الحبوب في اوكرانيا بعد امس بعد
بكره وكمان ثانيا هذا ضريع لاستخدام اي
اسلحه على اوكرانيا بالمناسبه اليوم نحن
وجدنا في فعل روسيا على مدينه خرسون هي
كاصفه هذه المدينه بشكل عنيف حصيله
الضحايا مقتولا اكثر من 16 شخصا وكمان
العد التجارها اكثر من 40 شخص روسيا
استهدفت قطار مع ركاب وكمان محطه ثقه
الحديد ومحلات داخل مدينه
روسيا تتقدم بالكثير من
المناطق وعلى بعض الجبهات لماذا هي بحاجه
ان تقوم بمثل هذه المسرحيه كما تسموها
انتم لاستهداف نفسها
هي اساسا هي اساسا ماضيه بهذه المعركه
ولديها تقدم وحتى يعني رئيس فاجنر كان
يتحدث بانه هناك تقدم كبير لقواته
اولا موجود هجوم مضادات قوات مصالحه روسيه
في بحر فقط يعني في منطقه اقليميه هي لا
توجد هجوم مضادات الشامله قوات مسلحه
روسيه لنكون صريحين
غرقت في مستانكا حرب الجيش رقم اثنين كما
تسمى روس هي عجزه باحتلال واستيلاء البلده
الضخمه
جيش رقم اثنين في العالم والان عند روسيا
نحن نشاهد
بهذا صعبه انا اعطاك طب بان هذه مسرحيه
كما انا كنت سوف يعتقد السفير يعني تقول
هذه مسرحيه ولكن هم يقولوا بانه رئيس
لينسكي يعني القرار ليس له بهذا الامر اذا
كان هذه العمليه قامت بها اوكرانيا ام لا
انتم كيف تردون هل حقيقه الرئيس زلينسكي
ليس هو صاحب القرار بكل خطوه وخاصه اذا
كانت عسكريه
جميله جوابهم معك بصراحه هذا غير معروف
ولكن كما افاد السيد زيلينسكي وكما نرى
اركان اوكرانيا اوكرانيا تستهدف عموما
وبصفه عمرو بنيت عسكريه تروسيه
من اوكرانيا حول هذا هجوم
بمصارات كيف ممكن بان حدثته هجوم بمصيرات
على القلب روسيا على
المستحيل بصراحه السيد متفيده بيقول لسنا
بحاجه لبقاء زيلينسكا على الحياه لاعلان
الاستسلام دائما هناك بديل يعني السيد كل
تصريحاته هو النيل من الرئيس زيلينسكي
وايضا من اعضاء حكومته
هل هناك حمايه كافيه وهل من الممكن ان
يحصل هذا الاستهداف هل تتوقعون حصوله
بصراحه انا اتذكر كانت عدد كبير من
المحاولات الاغتيالات على
اوكرانيا كمان على السياسيين الكبار
والاخرين هنا في اوكرانيا هذا اولا في
يعني انه واحد ان نحن ساميا عدد كثير من
الروس وسياسيين كبار روسيا حول تدمير
اوكرانيا الان حول استخدام اي اسلحه التي
موجوده في روسيا في اوكرانيا ومنها كمان
اصلح النوويه كما نقول بصراحه بصفه عملات
توجد اي مصلحه لاوكرانيا
لا مصلحه لاوكرانيا بذلك ولكن من الممكن
ان يكون هناك طرف يريد ان يورط اوكرانيا
هل من الممكن ان تقتنعوا بهذه الفكره التي
ايضا تتحدث عنها روسيا
كل شيء ممكن في هذه الحرب اكيد ممكن مثل
هذا الاستفزازات كمان استفزازات من طرف من
طرف اخر ليس فقط من كريم ولكن بالنسبه
لغريبه جدا قوات المصالحه روسيه عاجزه
لحمايه الكريم كما نقول من الممكن كمان
هذا الفلك المتطوعين الروس
هذا هجوم بمصارعراته على الكريم لانه ولكن
اين كل استقالات واقالات داخل وزاره
الدفاعات روسيا هذا كمان غريبه يعني برايك
عدم الاستقالات هو يطرح علامات استفهام
حول الطرف الذي قام بهذا العمل
بصراحه انا اعتقد بان في اقرب وقت خلال
هذا الايام نحن سوف نشاهد نهايه هذه
لمسرحيه روسيا نتيجه هذا المسرحيه روسيه
الا تتخوفون من هذا الرد العنيف الذي يمكن
ان يكون من قبل روسيا وخاصه بعد التاسع من
ايار بعد عيد النصر لانه مثلا ضيفنا الان
قال من الممكن ان يكون الرد بعد التاسع من
ايار بعد عيد النصر حتى لا يتاثر هذا
الاحتفال وهذه الذكرى
بصراحه كل شيء منتظر من لقاء او من زعيمه
متهور
ولكن بصراحه للاسف الشديد نحن هنا في
اوكرانيا قد تتعوضنا لكصف عنيف وباستخدام
اي اسلحه اوكرانيا حتى اسلحه
قادرون ان تصمدوا امام حرب مفتوحه يعني
حتى الان روسيا ما زالت متمسكه بكلمه
عمليه عسكريه ولكن اذا اعترفت بان هذه حرب
مفتوحه الى اي حد انتم قادرون ان تصمدوا
اللاعب الكلمات عمليه عسكريه او حرب اكيد
هذا ليست عمليه عسكريه هذا حرب
سبيل بالخصائص روسيه مقتولا اكثر من 190
الف
تصريحاته اركان اوكرانيا اكيد هذا حرب هو
حرب دمويه للغايه ولكن للاسف الشديد كما
نحن نشاهد بان في اقرب وقت سوف تكون سوف
يكون ترفعكم الصراع هنا في اوكرانيا حرب
سوف تكون الطويله اي مفاوضات اكيد مع
روسيا من الاربع مستحيلات لان اعترف محكمه
جنائيه دوليه بان بوتين هو مجرم وهذه
المحكمه اصدرت او اصدرت الامر حول القبض
على بوتين بهذا
اوروبا ايضا تعبت من هذه الحرب تعبت من
المساعدات التي تقدمها الى اوكرانيا
بالداخل الاوروبي انه نشاهد مظاهرات هناك
يعني المواطن في بعض الدول الاوروبيه هو
رافض لهذه الحرب لانه يعتبر بانها
سببت مشكله كبيره لاقتصاد بلاده الا
تتخوفون ان يتم التخلي عنكم
اكيد موجود الشوائخ حول هذا الامر ولكن
لنتذاكر بان في
اوكرانيا لم تحصل على امين الاتحاد
الاوروبي مساعده كبيره الى مساعده انسانيه
عندما هربوا من اوكرانيا عدد كبير ملايين
ملايين اطفال
اوكرانيا ولكن ثانيا واحد نخبه سياسيه
اوروبيه هي تدرك بان اليوم اوكرانيا بكره
لا توجد وبعد بكره وبعد ذلك لماذا
البناء مثل الاتحاد السوفيتي وامبراطوريه
روسيه وسوف تعود في منطقه نفوز روسيه كل
هذه البلدان من اتحاد السوفيتها السابق
وكمان من
بلدان الاشتراكيه ومن منها بولندا واكيد
منها
وبالمناسبه من المانيا كمان
والعالم هو يدركه اليوم اوكرانيا بكره ان
اتحاد اوروبي اوكر انيا هي مثل الحاجز بين
اوروبا حضريه والروس
اكيد اكيد تعبت غرب كمان نحن تعبنا من هذا
الحرب ولكن عندنا حل واحد هذا
كل الاسلحه من من غرب وطرد دروس من اراد
شكرا
بينما تتعرض روسيا لضربات في قلبها في
موسكو تعاني من جزء حيوي اخر في الاطراف
في شبه جزيره القرم التي تتعرض لاستهدافات
اوكرانيه متكررا متابع
ستبقى روسيه للابد تعهد قطعه عام 2014 عند
ضم شبه جزيره القرم وانتزاعها من الخريطه
الاوكرانيه غير ان انفجارات وغارات جويه
عده اظهرت وفق اعلام غربيه هشاشه الوجود
الروسي هناك كما ابرزت شبه الجزيره كجزء
من اهداف اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب للتغلب
على الرعب من الضروري ان ننتصر في المعركه
ضد العدوان الروسي وان نحرر القرم
الضربات الاوكرانيه في عمق شبه جزيره
القرم ومن ضمنها استهداف مقر اسطول البحر
الاسود الروسي في سيفا ستوبول هدفها
استنزاف اللوجستيات ومراكز القياده
والسيطره اي تعطيل خطوط الامداد الروسيه
اولا كما تهدف لعرقله توغل موسكو جنوبي
اوكرانيا ومخططها البرمائي للاندفاع غربا
باتجاه اوداسا وانشاء جسر بري الى مولدوفا
الا ان الضربه الكبرى تمثلت بالانفجار
الذي هز جسر الحيوي في اكتوبر 2022 ما ادى
لتدمير جزء منه وتعطيل حركه النقل وان
لفتره هذا الجسر هو الاطول في اوروبا
ويمتد لتسعه عشر كيلو مترا بلغت تكلفه
التشييده ثلاثه مليارات و600 مليون دولار
ويعد حلقه وصل بين شبه جزيره القرم ومنطقه
كريسنو دارك راي الروسيه شمالي القوقاز
نائب رئيس مجلس الدوم الروسي وص انها
الانفجار بمثابه اعلان حرب في معدته
الخارجيه الروسيه دليلا على ما وصفته
الطبيعه الارهابيه للحكومه الاوكرانيه اما
مستشار زيلنسكي فاكد ان الانفجار مجرد
بدايه طالما ان كل شيء غير شرعي يجب
تدميره وفق تعبيره الضربات الاوكرانيه في
شبه الجزيره جاءت متقطعه على مدى اشهر الا
ان وثيرتها ازدادت بشكل كبير خلال الايام
الاخيره وهي وفق الوصف الروسيه تعتبر
اعمالا ارهابيه وتخريبيه يسعى لتفكيك شبكه
منفذها
هذه الساعه الاخباريه من هذه التغطيه
انتهت اعود والتقيكم بعد ساعه من الان اما
الان تتابعون مع الزميل رشا نبيل الى
اللقاء لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات